(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) A partir desse momento, nós vamos analisar individualmente
os termos que você pode encontrar na análise
de uma matrícula de um imóvel e no
edital de um leilão.
Então vai ser aquele momento que eu falei
que eu vou explicar cada termo que você
pode encontrar.
Essa aula está subdividida em oito aulas, então
cada uma das oito aulas seguintes vai falar
especificamente sobre um termo.
Caso você encontre com um desses termos futuramente,
basta que você recorra à aula específica desse
termo que você vai conseguir entender perfeitamente sobre
o que se trata esse termo e qual
a consequência de existir esse termo na matrícula
do imóvel ou no edital do leilão.